you are listening to the dollop on me
all things comedy and network this is an
American history podcast each week I
Dave Anthony read a story from American
history to my nemesis Kira threatens
who's not your nemesis and also has no
idea what the topic is going to be about
this is part 2 of Ronald Reagan with
Patton Oswalt also and called it quote
is jam-packed jammed I'm the [ __ ] guy
they've okay names guarantee but it's
good is it for fun and this is not gonna
come particularly you both resent sick
arguments
oh how I was trying to throw a joke in
there but what it is is you go with Pat
now so now I just go also and then the
beam starts which it's pretty perfect
like a make-a-wish kid alright that's
the end of the talk about that we're
gonna be in Wisconsin will be in Madison
on October 18th we'll be in Milwaukee on
October 20th and then we go to Europe in
November we'll be in Oslo Stockholm
Amsterdam Copenhagen Amsterdam I think
okay I saw that too damn London
Manchester Glasgow Cardiff part of
Birmingham and then Dublin yeah what's
the venue in Dublin and I've got a
podcast calm and you can see all the
tour dates and then if you want to watch
the dynamic broadcast feed of this
episode you can go to the all things
come to YouTube page okay so where we
last left off oft was Ronald Reagan at
the end of 1981 is approval rating as a
49% we're in the middle of the cheese's
the cheese prices where I after the
cheese crisis to go off 1982 the White
House announced that Ronald would grant
tax exempt status to Bob Jones
University and other schools that
racially discriminated so fun start to
party right off the bat right good to be
back yeah we're back great
a week later Ronald phoned the
Washington Post to say he didn't know
there was a legal case pending about
segregated schools and then CBS dug up a
memo in which intervention was requested
in the Bob Hope even the Bob Jones case
by Bob Jones University in the memo
ronald wrote quote i think we should
there you go early eighties folks I
didn't know anything about it
did you write this on it though yeah
come here Lassie rain is already
applesauce what he sits down just hear a
gentle slosh Slurpee cup full of apple
sauce that was his brain listen can I
put some cinnamon
can I eat myself mommy so the tax cuts
that he'd asked for were back firing an
official recession was declared in 1982
unemployment went up to ten point eight
percent Jesus at a press conference
Ronald said quote there are a million
more people working than there were in
1980 that was a lie there were actually
a hundred thousand less working ronald
also kept telling reporters such a big
help wanted sections in the Sunday
newspaper meant unemployed people must
be lazy and would rather not work metric
do you think look lazy buggers no no
clean up the [ __ ] tub from Spencer and
he still wanted more tax cuts the
democratic-controlled Congress wanted to
raise taxes ronald went on TV and told
Americans again to call Congress and ask
for tax cuts and this time Americans did
not good knew Ronald finally was forced
to raise taxes the tax and fiscal
responsibility Act of 1982 passed ninety
eight billion dollars in new taxes he
would raise taxes ten more times over
his presidency the White House began
funding the Mujahideen in Afghanistan
who were fighting the Soviets this
included a young upstart fella named
Osama bin Laden that's nice we'll hear
this case by the way to move Janeane
were the heroes of Rambo three that's
with feed the Russian right
yeah oh great yeah I mean this is Mary
you go alone
Thank You Osama bin Laden
thanks a lot on his trailer door dude
[Laughter]
Ronald said he got a letter from the
Pope about US sanctions against the
Soviet Union he likes letters oh yeah a
pope letters got it I mean he's gonna be
like flapping his little hands oh yeah
and the Pope said he said quote the Pope
approves of what we've done so far
the Pope never said that okay kids a
month later
Ronald made up for it by falling asleep
in a meeting with the Pope at the
Vatican take that Jesus somebody send a
better opener next time do you wake him
what do you sleep in front of you you do
he woke himself because his head fell
down
oh so he did like what like middle
passengers do on planes it just makes it
more obvious big hats on the wall don't
worry mr. president Ronald was a master
of saying the wrong things at a press
conference Ronald said missiles quote
carried in ships or submarines can be
recalled if there has been a
miscalculation come back no one in the
press questioned him for saying missiles
fired from planes and submarines could
be recalled after being fired just let
him say it
because they caused half these half
those [ __ ] just one access right
they won't be on TV
see in the press corps and they don't
want to be the guy that's like hey no
they can't in the next day they're their
press passes gone well especially yeah
exactly especially now because now it's
like they're really I mean you could
just completely remove someone there's
not a press secretary yeah exactly I
mean no one in 1982 the CDC began
calling the mysterious disease affecting
mostly gay men acquired immunodeficiency
syndrome or
the total number of cases reporter was
771 total deaths 618 Ronald had not said
a thing about it
reporter Lester King solving asked press
secretary Larry speaks that bets the by
the way that this press secretary for
speaks almost the entire time his name
is speech Larry speak perfect his name
is a sentence it's also a children's
book yeah damn that's alright again this
is so many let's let's leave it alone
it's right there now Lester was a super
right-wing guy and he called gay rights
organizations quote the sodomy Lobby and
yet he was worried about its well you
can see why is also Lester does the
president have any reaction to the
announcement by the Centers for Disease
Control in Atlanta that aids is now an
epidemic in over six hundred cases over
a third of them have died it's known as
gay plague the press pool breaks into
laughter what no it is it's a pretty
serious thing one in every three people
that gets it have died and I wonder if
the president was aware of this Larry
Larry I don't have it press pool laughs
do you Lester you don't have it well I'm
relieved to hear that Larry the press
pool laughs do you know I don't you
didn't answer my question how do you
know the press pool laughs what is going
on
does the president in other words the
White House look on this is a great joke
Larry no I don't know anything about it
Lester what is going on why I don't
understand why are they all laughing is
it just the absurdity or just the fact
that it's even being brought up don't
care that people are dying and also back
then there was there was still that
thing of like oh you care about gay
people what are you gay right and that's
literally what Larry was doing right Oh
what do you I don't have it what are you
Yeah right
Highschool brothah right the only guy
who seems to care in the room as a crazy
right-wing guy who hates gay people and
yet he's like this is scary yeah yeah
yeah yeah
a few days later Larry introduced
Liberian leader Samuel kado as chairman
Moe there you go
chairman Moe doesn't work either way you
couldn't even get it wrong with a person
that exists yeah lemon moe there's
there's like there's ways to compete
confused that are acceptable sometimes
but not when you just quit president Moe
yeah anyway I'm done here yeah Dilek
come to power and a brutal bloody coup
in which most of the leaders of the
opposing party were executed on a beach
those suspended the Constitution around
the country committing atrocities so
Ronald had a nice meeting with him and
gave him tons of money there you go I
think he was that he was the guy we gave
the most money to in all of Africa
eighties squeaky wheel gets the grease
am I right people all right general
efraín ríos Montt took control of
guatemala in a bloody coup in March and
set up a military junta Ronald's State
Department praised Mont but human rights
workers journalists and the CIA said he
was committing massacres against the x'l
indigenous indigenous people the US
Embassy was investigating the massacres
when in December 1982 Ronald took a trip
to Latin America to meet with general
menthe afterwards Ronald was asked about
the massacres and he said quote I'm
inclined to believe they've been getting
a bum rap oh yeah they really do people
really do frown upon Massacre just do
not get the like it's not easy to do
it's not overnight right he then called
montt quote a man of great personal
integrity and commitment to massacring
people right it helped them out was it
Avenger evangelical Christian okay it
was in the name of God when he got back
when Ronald got back from Central
America he said quote well I learned a
lot you'd be surprised they are all
individual countries there you go maps
and globes
president so you're all different then
wow that's like when George W Bush did
his first tour and he like visited
England and and and he came back and
said well we we met them and we stood
our ground and was like both those are
our anyway and he called the the Greeks
cretians Oh fantastic
so the Reagan administration then
proposed renewing military aid to mount
from the New York Times quote the day
after Reagan's endorsement Guatemalan
soldiers arrived at a village called Dos
Equis and started killing the slaughter
went on for three days and by the time
it was over at least 162 people
including many children were dead the
Guatemalan army with Ronald support
wiped out over 600 entire villages and
killed every person in them military
assistance was secretly assumed by the
CIA and under Ronald in the 80s nearly
two hundred thousand people were killed
in Guatemala Mott was eventually
sentenced to 80 years in prison for
genocide in 2013 that's horrible but
eighty years for genocide well your but
that's life tacking on his life would
you call it life in 1983 there were 2807
reported cases of aids total deaths 2118
ronald had not said a word about how
Surgeon General C everett Koop was not
allowed to speak publicly about AIDS Pat
Buchanan wrote an op-ed in the New York
Post quote the poor homosexuals they
have declared war upon nature and now
nature is exacting an awful retribution
Pat had a regular job on CNN's crossfire
in the New Year an aide was quoted the
President and cap sit around and talk
about how work fair got surfers off the
beach in California they have no concept
of what is going on what we're surfers a
problem oh yeah just loafing around
surfers dude I said I'll go when I'm
ready get out of here we've got to close
the Gidget gap
you know you can get a woody in the
apparently ago on safari very brutal
with these bomb them yeah Ronald told
reporters about the 10 commandments of
Nicolae Lenin what one was quote
promises are like pie crusts made to be
broken
what what is happening right now okay
what just happen
Soviet scholars explain there is no such
thing as Lenin's ten commandments and
and that Lennon's first name was
vladimir holy [ __ ] fantastic [ __ ] go
off King a few days later as six
reporters asked Ronald questions in the
Oval Office the rest of the press corps
listened on a PA system they constantly
burst into laughter at his answers a New
York Times headline quote Reagan
misstatements getting less attention
Ronald's nominee to the board for
international broadcasting admitted in
his Senate hearing that he had many
investments in South Africa recently was
a guest of the apartheid government
belong to an all-white Country Club and
was director of a group that financed
research on the genetic inferiority of
blacks well come on don't tell me that
this man but he said quote I do not
believe in my heart that I am a racist
wait he's racist in a way that other
races can't ya hit feel like there's
races going I'm not wow that's
I don't find science like I bravery but
I hate that guy's racism like my racism
is like I don't like life and I just let
it go
I don't fund controlled experimental
bring metrics into the argument Wow
he withdrew as a nominee I mean come on
fight probably as soon as he finished
that sentence and I withdraw thank you
[Laughter]
James Watt Secretary of the Interior
says to a reporter quote if you want an
example of the failures of socialism
don't go to Russia come to America and
see the American Indian reservations how
did these all be way god damn insanity I
mean yeah like how did no one hit him
with a Bible literally you should be
stabbed in the neck if you say that so
much I literally legally be able to be
like there you go that's into you and
you're done
oh my god Wow I can't I don't have a
giant there must have been you know what
I bet that I bet that there were
reporters that actually wanted to push
back but they were constantly being hit
with things and made us kind of go and
then he just walked away I mean they're
like no comeback and he's gone yeah that
is that that is a tactic done yet yeah
say your speech on stun what he left 20
minutes ago yeah he's gone a month later
watt told lobbyists about his co leasing
Commission mm-hmm talking to group of
lobbyists and he says quote we have
every kind of mix you could have I have
a black I have a woman two Jews and a
[ __ ] and we have talent
again and we've got calluses what the
black and the [ __ ] and two ladies am
the Jew we have the Jew oh I remember
that I remember that very specifically
when he did that oh yeah I was and I was
young and I still were like that was one
of those it was because he do and you
can he watch the video of it he delivers
it like he's at ease landing the best
joke yeah he's gonna destroy the room in
the room is just what horror that went
on quite a while sir so Americans do not
react well to this even Republicans call
for his resignation but Ronald defence
him quote if I thought he was bigoted or
prejudiced he wouldn't be part of our
administration no he'd be running it
yeah exactly yeah Wow
so what resigns nineteen days later he
says quote the press tried to paint my
hat black but I had enough self-image to
know the Hat was white he then assumes a
crucifixion pose and photographers take
pictures what just happened what how do
you a yes God oh man imagine being
capable of this and also you've just
been accused of races everything is try
to make my hat black we know white is
good right I mean I'm not a racist
I'm nothing and feet connected boom yeah
in October 1983 suicide bombers blew up
buildings housing American and French
servicemembers in Beirut 241 Americans
and 58 French or killed two days later
Ronald invaded the Caribbean nation of
Grenada there we go
that's solved the prime minister sir
Gary wait for real look we don't know I
don't even think people think that my
name is Gary
a bit people are doing any more at the
time sir Gary was in the u.s. to address
the UN on quote the UFO phenomenon so
he's over there
by the way your your nations being
conveyed I'm sorry what I was talking
about anal probes and what's going on
don't do this now
Gary wanted a global task force to look
into UFOs and while he was in the US a
military hunter took over Grenada
[Music]
so Regan sent 7600 US troops who took
back Grenada I said it was to save the
medical students u.s. medical students
sure the UN condemned the invasion as a
flagrant violation of international law
but Ronald said Cuba was about about to
invade which was a complete lie sure an
Israeli newspaper reported that during a
meeting between Ronald and their prime
minister Ronald said he was an Army
photographer and had filmed the horrors
of Nazi concentration camps as they were
liberated
Ronald also said he had saved a copy of
the film in case there was a question of
how bad it was in the concentration
camps these Railly PM was so moved he
told his cabinet Ronald Reagan spent the
entire war in Hollywood is that the
genuine liar is applesauce yeah I think
it's Apple it's applesauce they're kind
of conflates these like roles he played
right yeah he didn't play role in this
but I read a guy trying to break it down
and it was basically that there was
video going around of that and he liked
burnin his memory and then as he gets
older and starts it seems tough right
didn't he also refer to soldiers
uniforms as costumes I don't know
probably
again on a film set whether costume look
at that wardrobe yeah so a metaphor
Jesse Jackson's like costumes are what
actors wear in a movie
exactly yeah it was all a blur ed meese
sorry
taking hate heat because he was making
constant comments about poor people
being lazy people began to call him Evan
easer Scrooge okay well that'll that'll
solve it a hero that'll show him a hero
yeah in December 1983 ed meese told the
National Press Club that Scrooge was
misunderstood what who is the who as
ever head Scrooge is back about Scrooge
yeah it's not acceptable behavior until
the ghosts quote if you really look at
all the facts he didn't exploit Bob
Cratchit documentary he watch yeah Bob
Cratchit was paid 10 shillings a week
which was a very good wage of the time
happening [ __ ] Bob and famine had good
cause to be happy with the situation he
lived in a house not a tenement his wife
didn't have to work he was able to
afford the traditional Christmas dinner
of roast goose and plum pudding so let's
be fair to Scrooge he had his faults but
he wasn't unfair to anyone he's an
economic hero mine honestly uh trickle
up economic cartoony openly monstrous
ghouls but like just running amok you
know we had this conversation with
someone like one of his buddies worship
a bit and then took another stage too
early or worse yet like he's had like
one of his kids came home was like we
read Christmas carol inscrutably you
know let me tell you something kids yeah
like yeah YouTube there's adding a lot
of sass in there yeah I mean like turn
the kids into monsters that you know oh
[ __ ] Scrooge provided jobs that there
are some quotes about Victorian scholars
being like [ __ ] what that's not jumping
out of windows
I'm done I can't not on this plane
[Laughter]
Ronald told the Congressional Medal of
Honor Society a story about a pilot who
was honored for going down with his
plane this was later revealed to be a
completely fake story
when questioned press secretary Larry
speaks said quote if you tell the same
story five times it's true damn Wow
that's lucky there you go the secret
yeah it is it's the secret is a secret a
columnist did some research and
discovered the story was a piece of
fiction from a 1944 issue of Reader's
Digest Reader's Digest like ransom note
yeah
cobbled together bits you know laughter
is the best medicine
anyway Ron what about the genocide oh
sorry I was just petting lassie over
here that's a stapler oh good girl
look at her leg go sorry Millie a couple
of weeks later Ronald told a rabbi he
filmed concentration camps during what's
happening over here but listen here's
one thing I've got imprint ixnay on the
tration Bobby I want to get a hair to
head there's the baseball scores
I read baseball scores to hit
[Laughter]
so do you think the cops have a chance I
do I really do they have no bench that
they don't but they're starting pitching
[Music]
Ronald had created a task force on food
assistance to get to the bottom of all
the bottom of all these stories about
hungry people right yeah three people
were his Loch Ness monster now the
pictures they see they're always blurry
I don't know very blurry after a few
months the tests the task force report
stated there was no evidence of great
hunger one member dr. George Graham said
quote black children are probably the
best nourished group in the United
States just horrifying prism to view
things yeah yeah Ronald was satisfied
with the report oh good the last Marines
were pulled out of Lebanon in February
1984 as an aide briefed reporters about
the pullout Ronald was thirty feet away
arm wrestling the publisher of a
bodybuilding magazine I don't have
anything to say a wolf
let him win her let him win or it's
literally like there's a toddler elbows
up the guys like Jesus Christ he was
nearby with his busybox oh god he was he
was busy pouring a cup of rice into an
empty Cup and back and forth yeah it's
really calm Wolfie wants him with my
magic beans
in April The Wall Street Journal
remember when the Wall Street Journal
actually broke stories Murdoch bought
them they were I mean there there were
it was a newspaper the newspaper in
April the Wall Street Journal revealed
Reagan had Nicaragua's harbors mind
which was a violation of international
law and an act of war Nicaragua sued in
the International Court of Justice which
ordered the United States to pay
reparations the White House said the
court had no jurisdiction over the US
and rejected the judgment the next day
Ronald declared law day USA quote
without law there can be no freedom only
chaos and disorder I mean it's just like
[Laughter]
I said it's Lotte now we have law there
we go now we can mine wherever we want
no no the carpet is now lava don't walk
on there it's giving a press conference
to a wall thank you I'm gonna take
questions now from the bowling trophy at
a press conference Ronald claimed his
environmental record was quote one of
the best-kept secrets of his presidency
aha they kept it really really good job
of that one a reporter asked how his
disgraced and fired ex Eph he fit in
with that
and Larry speaks or the lights turned
off in the darkness Ronald said quote my
guardian says I can't speak
[Laughter]
what is it a preschool this happened
yeah secretary literally called the
timeout call they call the goddamn
timeout darkness wicked City Quebec well
excuse me we're adults what happened oh
my god Gardi Oh fantastic
okay I don't want to not have juice and
crackers
he won't cut the crusts off if I speak
night-night we all go now now
[Laughter]
boom he did not go boom both president
did not go boom boom boom
around this time a pattern began to
emerge that was first noticed on August
1st 1984 Ronald was asked a question by
reporters about arms control and there
at the ranch and he stands silently
grunting and shrugging until Nancy until
Nancy lowered her head and quietly said
oh I've seen this clip doing everything
we can
Ronald then said quote we're doing
everything we can this then happened
repeatedly for the rest of his
presidency
yeah when mommy cyrano de bergerac some
real cowboy hat on he's waving we're
doing everything we can we kept it over
and over Wow
the Congressional study came out showing
Ronald's cuts pushed 500,000 people into
poverty
the majority children poverty was that
now at an 18-year high Walter Mondale
won the Democratic Party nomination and
during the campaign Ronald had moments
of incoherence and was not sharp in
debates in one debate he blanked out at
one point and during his closing
argument he said quote I'm all confused
now I remembered that footage - he is he
was saved by them calling time because
he literally to go and as I Drive up
that California it was yeah he's clearly
spent they go that's time sir and if
they had not called time god knows what
he would have said that might have sunk
it he looks so crazy Wow
I remember that so clearly no concern
from people leads the White House to
have a doctor declare Ronald is in his
quote mentally alert right right oh they
haven't been doing for the other years
for some reason did he identify a lion
on a test that's right triangle in the
triangle right like that Ronnie boom but
Americans did not like any negative news
about Ronald reporter Leslie Stahl said
quote the idea that the public has come
to feel they have a vested interest in
protecting him is fascinating to me
Jimmy Carter's take was quote President
Reagan doesn't always check the facts
before he makes statements and the press
accepts it as kind of amusing right yeah
which is real it was entertaining
right right right and now we're in the
mutant version of the right so that the
Chicago Tribune wrote quote mr. Reagan's
ignorance about the Soviet Union and his
airheaded rhetoric on the issues of
foreign policy in arms control have
reached the limit of tolerance and have
become an embarrassment to the US and a
danger to world peace this is part of
their endorsement of Ronald Reagan oh my
god I'm sorry
go back wait yes this is part of their
endorsement this guy is a pudding-headed
mr. maniac mr. Reagan's ignorance about
the Soviet Union and his airheaded
rhetoric on the issues of foreign policy
and arms control have reached the limit
of tolerance and have become an
embarrassment to the US and a danger to
world peace
anyway vote for what I want to read the
rest of that stick what how do they then
pull out of that yeah right where's the
switch I think because they say the
economy is doing better and you know
they go because Mondale also said he was
gonna raise taxes right right Vegas I
know he just came out and said I'm gonna
raise tax in the Reagan well - he's just
not gonna tell you well right okay yeah
yeah yes Ronald won every single state
except for Minnesota yep he was the
oldest president elected 73 years old a
new staff came in chief of staff Don
Regan was a former marine commander and
chairman and CEO of Merrill Lynch he was
worth 40 million dollars okay get him in
that they understand the plight of the
everyman oh yeah Pat Buchanan okay
crossfire host writer of the horrible
anti-gay op-ed admirer of Nazis and
Holocaust denier became the new White
House communications director ah right
feels like a good wrestling Israeli for
years Ronald got much of his information
from the extremely right-wing Human
Events Magazine
he read it religiously and made notes
getting emotional yeah all right
his new aides were quote horrified that
he was reading it I'm surprised he's
allowed to call his aides aids at this
[Laughter]
yeah Don Regan tried to stop the
subscription from reaching him but it
went to the residence he tried to get
aides to hide it when Ronald realized
what was going on he ordered several
subscriptions so things are totally
normal in 1984 there were seven thousand
two hundred and thirty nine reported
cases of AIDS in the u.s. total deaths
were five thousand five hundred ninety
six Ronald still had said nothing
scientists concluded AIDS was caused by
HIV Lester at a press conference Lester
is he going to do anything Larry Larry
Lester I have not heard him express
anything sorry Lester you mean he has
expressed no opinion about this epidemic
Larry trying to keep from laughing no
but I must confess I haven't asked him
about it Lester will you ask him Larry
Larry have you been checked the press
pool burst into laughter it's the would
you gay yeah and it's working yeah
that's enough yeah that's enough that's
an unidentified person in the press pool
is the president gonna ban mouth to
mouth kissing Lester what pardon I
didn't hear your answer Larry laughing
it's hard work I don't get paid enough
is there anything else we need to do
here that's crazy
could you imagine being a gay person no
we were in San Francisco it was a
[ __ ] nightmare to watch and this is
what's going on with your government
imagine having AIDS and like being
scared out of your [ __ ] and that's
them and they're doing like 50 style
jokes about right right and it's
crushing and it's yeah it's crushing and
there's and there's nowhere to go
there's there's nowhere to go
Rock Hudson went to France for an
experimental treatment and had trouble
getting admitted to the hospital he was
a long time for
of Ronald and Nancy Hudson's agent
reached out and asked the White House
for help an aide asked Nancy if they
should intervene she says no yeah
because it wasn't affecting her directly
racism care for the 40th anniversary of
VE Day
Ronald accepts an invitation from the
German Chancellor to visit a German
military cemetery in Bitburg Nancy no
Nicks is an additional visit to Dachau
because it is quote too negative and
depressing well yeah that's I mean that
was that's the main thing about what was
very negative yeah it's very true and
Nancy a gift shop is great unbelievable
I also every new probably would be tough
because Ronald would just go there and
be like wow I remember when I figured
out the crew was here Terry with the
boom in classic Gary the White House
says Ronald will really fat this wreath
at the cemetery only to learn 49 members
of Hitler's SS are buried there Don
Regan tells Ronald not to go ronald
quote i've promised what ronald tells
the press quote we have to put the past
behind us the soldiers were victims just
as surely as the victims in the
concentration camp same thing
know what yeah so present United States
of America said that Nazi SS with the
same kind of victims as the people the
Nazi SS [ __ ] murder genocide genocide
same thing same deal to Ronald Reagan
and well has the press corps handling
this they're just like Ron Ronnie
love the new stuff yeah and also and I
it wasn't that there there wasn't the
infrastructure that we have now where
people could express her admiration
right this but he was getting a lot of
support right cuz of this [ __ ] from
white supremacists ratted you know now
that you know David Duke and all these
people that storm front they Thank You
Donald
back then it was very quietly right
fifty two percent of people thought he
shouldn't go that means forty eight
percent forty eight percent really yeah
great fine Senate and House passed
resolutions against him going at the
White House a concentration camp
survivor just happens to be giving a
medal getting a medal oh boy so right
when this is happening this guy just has
him getting a medal at the time he gives
a speech directly to Ronald asking him
not to go and says quote your place is
with the victims of the SS Ronald
literally makes a sad face are you being
mean to me yeah and now to give the
Congressional Medal of Honor
so from Ronald's diary quote don't know
poor beast of a thing to go through
I mean why slides drawings of slides did
you ever have a diary for your president
don't have a diary yeah I need a chef's
hat for tomorrow
[Laughter]
four miles diary quote the uproar about
my trip to Germany and the Bitburg
cemetery was cover stuff in Newsweek and
time they just won't stop well I'm going
not gonna cancel anything no matter how
much the bastards scream the politicians
inability to just say you [ __ ] up
[ __ ] up I'm not gonna go yeah right
you know what I yeah I thought it over I
changed my mind I got more information
you know what like what people do 80
times a day it shows you all the time it
shows like process and thought and yeah
anyway he went to Bitburg and laid down
a wreath in the place of the SS were
well we got a great Ramone song out of
it so upon returning from his masterful
PR trip
Ronald pushes Congress to fund the
Contras at one point he said quote just
had a verbal message delivered to me
from Pope John Paul urges for us to
continue our efforts in Central America
the Vatican immediately issues a denial
he passed out here once he napped here
there is a New York Times Magazine
article titled the mind of President
Reagan in which an aide says quote you
have to treat him as if you were the
director and he was the actor and you
tell him what to say and what not to say
and only then does he say the right
thing that's really reassuring that's
good
Wow a couple of days later Princess
Diana visits and they hold the dinner
for her and Ronald toasts Princess Diana
and calls her Princess David nobody can
over nobody fine let's just keep going
I'd like to send a greeting to princess
Dakin and a beautiful husband Charlotte
okay
sure they glad they made the trip cool
so seven yeah
seven American hostages are being held
in Beirut by different groups a plan is
created to sell weapons to Israel and
then Israel would sell other weapons to
Iran then Iran might possibly release
the hostages cool
Ronald's diary quote it could be a heart
it could be a breakthrough on getting
our seven kidnapped victims back Oliver
North is brought in to run the operation
and the operation has expanded now
Congress has forbidden the u.s. from
sending money to Contras so what if the
Saudis gave the Contras 1 million
dollars a month because we were selling
the weapons brilliant all of manure sets
up accounts for the Saudis to put money
into other countries put my in even Ross
Perot kicks in 2 million copies and then
money for the Contras comes from drug
sales
the CIA is delivering weapons to the
Contras and then flying a Plane full of
cocaine to sell in the u.s. crazy George
Bush is in charge of all of this it is
suggested to north they cut out Israel
and just sell the weapons straight to
Iran so they do they mark up the price
from 3.7 million to 10 million and give
the extra profit to the Contras Wow
it's a good [ __ ] deal right out the
middleman right baby oh yes yeah
that is crazy and so like I mean brazen
obviously yeah yeah White House
communications director Pat Buchanan is
a huge fan of South African apartheid
and he gives roughly Sun City and he
gives Ronald right-wing propaganda
attacking anti-apartheid protests in a
radio interview on August 24th 1985
Ronald says South Africa has quote
eliminated the segregation that we once
had in our own country the type of thing
where hotels and restaurants and places
of entertainment and so forth were
segregated that has all been eliminated
what with apartheid black people in
South Africa can vote and they can't use
public facilities no it's not I mean an
apartheid we apartheid is segregation we
it's like it's yes it's it's like you're
cold by giving you the flu yeah right
yeah so Buchanan's just feeding him
[ __ ] [ __ ] and he's just a second
yeah it's like that age where like you
can get your kids to swear but it
doesn't really impact right in the
future it's like right now you've got a
real sweet spot yeah it was whispered in
his ear
Ronald's ambassador to the UN vetoes a
UN Security Council resolution
condemning apartheid in 1985 there now
15,000 527 reporter cases of AIDS twelve
thousand five hundred and twenty nine
deaths
Ronald finally says the word aids in
public but does not address the nation
people are now losing their minds over
AIDS they're calling for quarantines
nurses are quitting instead of treating
AIDS patients funeral directors are
refusing to embalm the dead even Pat
Buchanan wants the President to address
AIDS in a speech the president has asked
if he would send his child to a school
with a child who had AIDS and Ronald
says he understands both sides oh my god
what the house of two boys with AIDS who
get a court order to attend school in
Florida is burned down Rock Hudson
announces he has AIDS and dies soon
after Ronald and Nancy say nothing but
he did add AIDS jokes to his joke
repertoire quote one doctor said to the
other I've got the solution I served
them a special dinner of crepes and
filet of sole what does that do it's not
a cure no it's not said the doctor but
the advantage is that I can just slide
it under the door and I don't have to
touch them Ronald would then laugh and
laugh and laugh at his own joke and he
told the joke many times and I'm sure it
killed one of those monsters that he
in December 1985 60 minutes does a
segment on the state of Ronald's mind Oh
play a Berkeley professor argues that
Ronald can't tell the difference between
reality and movies 50% of time I think
I'm in Tron let me take Morpheus again
then 60 minutes traces the evolution of
one of Ronald's anecdotes from where he
credits his credits it as a movie scene
to where he tells it as if it actually
had no was like clips like it keeps yeah
it's like they don't break it down all
the way it is the least popular segment
in 60 minutes history Wow so we just
didn't get like hate mail and staff
people are furious
don't ruin our illusion yeah which is so
great I mean it is so crazy I think
there's also a love because remember
there's the nukes thing there because I
was I was terrified you know people are
scared any clearer but I was terrified
than a man without a brain was in charge
of the nuclear weapon right so I think
there's a level of people not wanting to
think this can possibly be redone fátima
and that also because he was an actor
who could seem presidential they're like
don't take away the security boy right
yeah don't take it don't take away my
delusion cuz it makes me happy I hate it
and we are still there I mean you really
are still there where it's just like
yeah I just rather believe yeah like let
me leave out cookies for Santa yeah
Ronald has a third Kintz skin cancer
removed from his nose reporters question
him about the reoccurrence Ronald quote
I'm not a medical I'm not a lawyer and
I'm not a medical either
but I am reading for the part of medical
later today on LaBrea right but I am a
shoe booty the children live inside me
here's one mommy turn the lights off
Ronald is becoming more and more
irritated with reporters and at one
point is caught on tape telling calling
them sons of [ __ ] when asked about it
Larry speaks explain Ronald said quote
it's sunny and you're rich oh wow Larry
there's that charm he's taking his son
to the beach hey I'm Lorraine the space
shuttle Challenger explodes On January
28th 1986 Pat Buchanan is asked what the
president's initial reaction was quote
the president was stunned he said
something like isn't that the one with
the teacher on it Wow there is really he
gives a great speech about the disaster
on TV and his approval rating shoots up
to 78% Spaceship people was inside it
yes in January 1986 Ronald helps brutal
dictators jean-claude baby doc do EA of
Haiti and fernette Fernan Marcos of the
Philippines escape their just fates
during revolts so they can live out
their lives in wealth and luxury both
murdered tons of people but were
anti-communist Ronald gives Marcos
sanctuary in the u.s. they were flown to
Guam with 89 aides jewelry gold bars and
7 million in cash Wow
by 1986 there were 20,000 712 reported
cases of AIDS total dead 24,000 559
Ronald says nothing but his budget calls
for deep cuts to AIDS research there you
go at the 1986 centenary rededication of
the Statue of Liberty the Reagan's are
sitting next to a french president
Mitterrand and his wife on the stage Bob
Hill here we go
says quote
I just heard that the Statue of Liberty
has AIDS
did I mention 25,000 people are dead
25,000 I know this story by the way I
just heard that the Statue of Liberty
has AIDS but she doesn't know if she got
it from the mouth of the Hudson or the
Staten Island Ferry oh god the TV
cameras show the Reagan's heads going
back and laughing as the minions look
appalled oh my god although I will look
that yes that was awful Bob Hope's
daughter read him the riot act on that
no-good subsequently went back on TV and
was like you know what I was wrong with
me to do that he actually apologized for
okay expressed regret in the change and
a change of opinion yeah Wow because his
daughter Lighting's like Bob sit down I
think you have to at some point you
gotta realize old people are old and
they're doing a thing and then if they
change good it's shitty that he said
that yes but it's horrible yeah but
unlike Ron he was like oh [ __ ] I didn't
know yeah he had an actual change yes
yeah whereas before in the early in the
late 60s he did something and and all
these people like it was he's like an
army thing and they were like how can
you do this like during Vietnam and he
actually was like you know what I didn't
think about that
yeah so Wow just like comedians today
exactly [ __ ] babies so Ronald's
longtime friend and advisor
Roy Cohn died of AIDS the Reagan's did
not go to his funeral
by 1987 the total number of reported
AIDS cases in the u.s. was 50,000 total
dead 40,000 849 and he's still cutting
the funding and all the I mean yeah he
asked for amount of funding and Congress
is like yeah we're gonna double that
like he just Reagan's ex director of the
Office of Management and Budget releases
a book an excerpt is printed in Newsweek
Ronald is portrayed as clueless in in at
a description of the Secretary of
Defense is defending his huge military
budget by showing Ronald cartoon
drawings of soldiers in different states
of preparedness No
no no no no no no no no no and I go
there really wrong
not really but still am I the one in the
dress I'm not sure we must get the
Abrams tank to protect brave Beetle
Bailey along with Sarge Sarge his dog
Otto
he's our own oh really is get me go get
me Gomer Pyle so I mean he literally he
is literally a child they're living
right there and he's showing him how he
needs different amounts of money for the
for the defense budget by showing
pictures of soldiers with like less
equipment like mental in capability and
musi is very sad it's crazy when people
shield yes the president that's the
reality that's the problem here by it's
not only that but America seeing it and
ignore it right angry when people aren't
being there right hey I think there
might be a problem should you shut up
it's yeah we still experience it with
well all the time I mean after this
comes out the press focuses on the ex
cabinet member betraying the president
instead of the content of the book and
of course on April 5th Libya bombs a
West Berlin nightclub killing three
people including a US servicemen Ronald
then drops 60 tons of munitions on Libya
on April 14th two of Qaddafi sons are
injured and an infant daughter is killed
it is a clear assassination attempt on
Qaddafi which is illegal and that's it
what happens yeah well the Senate I
think that'll all ended pretty well for
Qaddafi if memory serves in July
ed meese gets a 1960 page report on
pornography that he had ordered from a
commission to study porn I mean if this
isn't some dude just getting ready to
really perv out on a Sunday night oh you
got that all right let me just have a
look
take a look at here see you next month
the study cost $500,000 the government
charges $35 to get a two-volume
collection yeah it becomes a collector's
item because it may be the best listing
for porn in the world hell yeah
ed meese after dark this handsomely
bound to volume set has got all of your
favorite yeah including yank my doodle
it's a dandy the greatest glory ever
hold I think my Hinkley yes it would
just had titles listed there you go on
October 5th 1986 a plane carrying
weapons is shot down by this sand Denise
does over Nicaragua the only survivor
says he works for the CIA a month later
a Lebanese news magazine prints and
expose outlining the arms for hostages
deal Regan goes on TV to deny the story
79 percent of people don't believe him
Wow
whoa fine what but hang on why do we go
back and forth as a public and what is
he don't be mean to this guy let's leave
and then wet [ __ ] I know it's just
so I was weird
yeah he then goes on TV to say he knew
nothing about it and Poindexter resigned
and North was fired right a good look
for yours yes really
he later tells North quote this is gonna
make a great movie one day I think it
already might be I need to go ten to
here's the pic cocaine capers and we get
Joe Piscopo and we are gonna get a
monkey that looks like the State of the
Union yeah
yeah clear my sight lines please the
grips are moving back tired I get an
Apple box and by that I mean a box full
of apples that's just and special
prosecutor Lawrence Walsh is brought in
to investigate in an interview with Time
magazine Ronald says he only found out a
few days before the link between the
Iranian arm sales amount of Contras I
mean but he didn't blame his staff quote
Lieutenant Colonel Oliver North was
involved in all our operations he has a
fine record he is a national hero my
only criticism is that I wasn't told
everything
Ronald then blames the press quote what
what is driving me up the wall is that
this wasn't a failure until the press
got a tip from that rag in Beirut and
began to play it up I told them that
publicly that publicity could destroy
this that it could get people killed and
they went right on the whole thing boils
down to a great irresponsibility on the
part of the press I mean unbelievable
really at least these are crimes in the
paper like this and he and it's amazing
that he can still kind of function when
he needs to just [ __ ] he's like gets
himself off your mat and is able to he's
got this like weird like nitro tank for
when he needs me right right I mean he's
literally talking about treason yes and
he's calling the rags like it's like
yeah a gossip rag
Ronald's approval rating is now 46% yeah
Don Regan loses it in a staff meeting
and puts the blame for iran-contra on
Robert Robert McFarlane who he owes
always hated he yells quote let's not
forget whose idea this was it was buds
idea when you give lousy advice you get
lousy results this is leaked to the
press Nancy wants Don Regan out as chief
of staff and she's leaking stuff oh she
pressures Ronald so much on a getaway to
Camp David that he turns around and
screams at her quote get off my goddamn
back oh yes Ron yes Ron
it's weird how iran-contra will make you
freak out a little bit yeah yeah yeah
when you do the most massive treason in
US history gets you a little tense they
said in Cosmo it's one of the five
reasons most couple cooler iran-contra
his approval rating is now at forty one
percent
Wow Ronald has prostate surgery and
answer Nancy orders he do nothing for
six weeks
her astrologer quote told her that
January was a bad month for the
president to be met for the president
god
I mean literally they asked an
astrologer about every single every move
literally every single thing here's the
news show I want to see it's about the
astrologer living in the White House
like the cakewalk life but also
realizing like I can affect us part yes
merica I mean side what goes the
Reagan's are said to be stunned that
their longtime allies are not backing
them huge right wing douchebag
Congressman Bob Dornan quote oh when
someone says but he was giving arms to
people he knew had killed our Marines
it's hard to respond to that yeah isn't
it for Bob for Bob to say yeah Bob
Dornan is a [ __ ] lunatic yeah for him
to go against Reagan is Wow oh yeah yeah
that's when they knew they'd cross the
Rubicon like do we lose Dorn again we're
part right we're [ __ ] on this one 78%
of Americans believe there is a cover-up
it comes out that they sent the Iranians
a cake at one point hey oh he shouldn't
have
Oh red velvet we can't get that I can't
stay mad at you
and it's Braille to what and it's on the
table it says thank you for the hostage
the hostages with a candle like their
candle so much to blow it out MacFarlane
goes on Nightline to distance himself
from the cake situation Kate quote there
was a cake on a mission alright there
was a cake we admit the cake you happy
wouldn't burn all right track down the
cake all right all right
apparently you were talking to deep
frosting and he leaked it we're calling
the Baker to Capitol Hill what [ __ ]
[ __ ] said bring an ice cream cake
Tiran which what are you [ __ ] goddamn
desert climate quote there was a cake on
a mission I didn't buy it
bake it cook it eat it presented or
otherwise get involved with it the cake
was not products defense the cake was
the product of a spontaneous idea of
Colonel North so Oliver North was like
send him a cake they're like yeah for
sure he came up the idea of sending him
a cake he'll Wow a month later
MacFarlane tries to kill himself by
taking 20 volume yeah and that's a lot
of guilty the tower Commission had been
put together to look into iran-contra
when the tower report is delivered to
Ronald it says he traded guns for
hostages and his quote detached style in
which considerable authority was
delegated to subordinates allowed
iran-contra to move forward without
adequate scrutiny or supervision Ronald
is upset but remains in denial Don Regan
is savaged in the report and then Don
finds out he's fired when the press
announces Howard Baker is the new chief
of staff oh wow it is believed that
Nancy did this yeah so there really is
no president in this row it's just sort
of like this is like Woodrow Wilson
after this right it's a costume yeah
yeah it really is speaking to the
American camping Association Nancy says
of Don Regan quote I don't think most
people associate me with leeches or how
to get them off but I know how to get
them off I'm an expert at it
and then she turned into a spider can
you talk about something I typed on down
put a hot poker in his ass all right
Nancy we were kind of looking for small
recipes you thought you're gonna be
listed on some of your favorites more
recipes book this the press corps asks
Larry speaks about the report describing
Reagan as incredibly ignorant he tells
the press to quote bug off and calls a
New York Times article quote phooey pH
ooe why is this man a comic strip yet
did he like a stream on the 76th
birthday
Ronald enters a room filled of staff
gathered for a surprise party
he is very startled and remained so
until Nancy whispers quote it's your
staff what
who are these doggies
on March 4th 1987 Ronald addressed the
nation on TV quote a few months ago I
told the American people I did not trade
arms for hostages my heart and my best
intentions still tell me that is true
but the facts and evidence tell me it is
not yeah paint women so what he's saying
is I did do it even though I believed
really hard that I didn't yeah that's
how that translates yeah and it really
is like a very weird offense but yeah
like it doesn't make
any inside I wanna do it outside I did I
know I had I call him the American
people to clap really hard because if
you believe that I didn't do it come on
everybody two three four Wow Congress
holds hearings Oliver North is given
congressional immunity and admits
everything he admits lyin to Congress
and covering for Ronald his hometown
holds a parade in his honor
sure Ronald starts to pretend he has
laryngitis and reporters asking
questions what fantastic president is
not yeah yeah you know today is
backwards day so I can't answer quick
alright everyone the president is now a
sitcom premise each week eleven new
quirk let's go flush the toilet while
he's in the shower
next week he's gonna hit his head and
become evil Ron Reagan and we're gonna
call him wrasse now I know that you guys
are planning a surprise party but he
thinks you're planning on murdering him
he's overhearing it wrong so that's the
energy were with he thinks the cake is a
bomb and that the candles are fuses
surprise actually [ __ ] his pants I've
never seen that before
Oh God on April 1st 1987 Ronald makes
his first public speech about AIDS quote
April Fool's right there oh my god
[ __ ] April Fool's Day of course god
you're right Wow anyway quote when it
comes to preventing aids don't medicine
in morality teach the same lessons [ __ ]
off I mean really it is unbelievable he
did not mention safe sex he did to say
they could do sex education in schools
if they taught abstinence mm-hmm
and Nancy could teach a class on sucking
[ __ ] she's unbelievable like your [ __ ]
in a tongue blender I don't like telling
tales out of school but I saw her make
Phil Silvers glasses fly off
she blew Cary Grant so hard the back of
his head collapsed in she blew George
Burns while shooting on a glass table
over Danny Thomas that's some nice stuff
man I said that's my girl
we turned it into a play no we didn't
run oh I wrote a one-man musical about
it now you did I'm gonna go to my
journal that's yellow pages so yeah so a
presidential aids Commission is formed
ronald agrees to put one homosexual on
the thirteen member board the rest are
conservatives what a great position for
that person yeah right thanks
we just want to like shut down
bathhouses and quarantine right right
the u.s. then shuts down the border to
immigrants with HIV
Ronald goes on a nine-day European tour
this is when he says quote mr. Gorbachev
tear down this wall it plays on TVs
around the world but he still has a 42
percent approval rating in the u.s.
Ronald was hard of hearing and begins
cupping his hand over his ear pretending
he can't hear reporters questions
what's the laryngitis thing Wow what are
we gonna do for sweeps I'm blind what I
can't see your words I'm three kids in
the president outfit they also increased
the noise of the helicopter when he gets
off so reporters have a hard time
questioning that and having traction
hang on whoa say that again Dave I just
think if we make the helicopter louder
then they can't hear the quantization
get the mufflers off of marine one right
now I have nine whistling penis yes we
do
oh my god hang on wait there's always an
angry cockatoo next I just need the loud
the guy could do screaming I can't
understand I'm sorry mr. peppers mr.
peppers as me I can't take any questions
mr. peppers as a cold
[Laughter]
that's a longboard big cut oh that's at
Spruce busy words today it's the
noisiest wood but what are the odds
so ronald nominates robert bork as his
third supreme court pick on july 1st
1987 bork is super right wing democrats
defeat him 42 to 58 and Republicans are
furious
it was um that was Teddy's thing Bork
becomes a verb the Republicans are
literally still holding a grudge yeah oh
yeah they literally think that them
taking garland away not allowing Obama
to have a paper year is they think it's
making up for that so Ron's next pick
Douglas Ginsburg admits his wife
performed abortions and then he admits
he smoked pot and Ronald withdraws the
nomination Wow pull that guy's side now
we lie at the total [ __ ] I have
smoked weed and my wife has done that
yes yeah all right thanks everybody
that's
I used to [ __ ] pigs in my fraternity I'm
gonna go to the PF Changs down the
street I'm outta here that's my time
thank you guys I yield back the balance
of my time thank you my time I [ __ ] a
goat all right thank you
wait now I'm [ __ ] one now so uh
Anthony Kennedy is the next choice and
he's confirmed ninety-seven is zero the
stock market plummets in October it's
the largest drop ever that's black
Monday right I know is it black I think
it might be yeah it was really big yeah
it was crazy Nancy has breast cancer and
gets a radical mastectomy mm-hmm no more
money is coming in so the conscious
scientists ceasefire agreement in March
88 it just goes to show how many people
they got to kill because we were giving
exactly a federal grand jury returns a
23 count indictment against Oliver North
and three others John Poindexter takes
the fault testifying he decided not to
inform the president Ronald holds a
press conference and lies quote from all
the investigation and everything else we
don't know where that money came from
and we don't know where it went Wow
it's just money came and I don't know
comes and it goes again that's tiny
that's the new ambassador of elephant
who led a screaming goat in here
look at that what else we're opening a
nursery in here there's gonna be a lot
of kids screaming okay all right I'm
gonna take this wandering cymbal
practice asked about McFarland's guilty
plea Ronald said quote he just pleaded
guilty to not telling Congress anything
it wanted to know I've done that myself
and then he caught himself quote no
don't distort that no I just mean I
think Congress would like to be asking
questions about almost anything again
George Bush runs for president and
Ronald campaigns for him
Bush claims he had no idea about
iran-contra in truth it was run out of
his office and in his diary he wrote he
was one of the few people who knew all
of the details Bush April Evans really
doing some treason today I mean these
Diaries are a little honest I know you
think they'd be coded like how prisoners
write letters to each other or something
[ __ ] you know so Bush is elected in his
victory speech he thinks ronald quote
one of the most decent men I've ever met
imagine saying that Ronald left office
with the highest approval rating since
FDR the anti FDR right but just after
all after all of this yeah I couldn't
figure it like I died I didn't write it
down but yeah it's got to be way up
there but it's like after all I guess we
weren't 40% for so [ __ ] long and then
and then all that came out was bad [ __ ]
yeah yeah there was nothing that was
good we do like this wiry tail to
mastectomy that might have had something
right but it's just [ __ ] crazy yeah
and it is on us it's another person you
know sorrowful yeah so
he raised taxes 11 times but the overall
tax burden went down unemployment went
down right the economy was decided but
in 87 yeah it was still decent 87
inflation dropped the GDP grew military
spending increased Social Services
dropped the national debt tripled the
income gap widened 18 friends bought the
Reagan's a house in Santa Barbara for
2.5 million this is the third house
someone else bought for them yep Time
magazine reports Nancy had continued to
secretly borrow designer clothing during
her entire time in the White House which
is a crime Wow
she violated the 1978 ethics and
government Act requiring high-ranking
officials to report gifts above $35 but
a designer tells time they were not
considered gifts quote we think of it as
loans she promised to return all of the
dresses but she never did okay so that's
a gift and she'd now flown them out to
Santa Barbara there you go
but if they are loans according to tax
experts she could have been found guilty
of evading taxes on 1 million worth of
taxable income after the time story
breaks Nancy has her assistants begin
returning the dresses quietly yeah in
1988 there are 82 thousand six hundred
three hundred and sixty two cases of
AIDS and sixty 1816 deaths Ronald Reagan
did not say a word about AIDS in 1988
Surgeon General coop did put out a
pamphlet called understanding AIDS it
was mailed to 107 million homes the
largest mass mailing in American history
coop might be the only good person in
Reagan's entire okay well yeah he was
very upset about what was happening
right and he's like a right-wing
Christian but he was also right he
walked it like he talked it right yeah
Donald Regan's book came out in May
quote virtually every major move and
decision the Reagan's made during my
time as White House chief of staff was
cleared in advance with a woman in San
Francisco who drew up horoscopes to make
sure the guys were in favorable
alignment for the enterprise oh my god
that's the chief of staff so it is it is
ironic that the first like one of the
most conservative presidencies was kind
of
by a hippie out of San Francisco weird
oh man what is what is moonflowers say I
should do about like of all the the fact
that that is in the atmosphere around
him is unbelievable strange
Ronald Nancy write memoirs she writes
that wearing clothes from designers was
good for the fashion industry
oh yeah right it was a job creator but
the author of the ethics and government
Act says quote that's not a legal
defense that's a public relations
defense you are dealing with elected
officials who are controlled by a series
of laws and rules that bar or limit the
kinds of things they can receive from
outsiders it then comes out that Nancy's
hairdresser was paid for by Claire all
costing the company more than a hundred
thousand dollars also blatantly illegal
and her personal manicurist flew in
weekly from LA to do her nails which she
also denies price there were no [ __ ]
manicures and yes well no the astrologer
said she had to use one on a hat yeah
she needed [ __ ] barbs to do yeah yeah
the IRS opens an investigation by 1992
the IRS to determine the Reagan's failed
to include three million worth of
clothing on their tax returns and they
pay a large amount of back taxes oh wow
but that's easy because someone bought
him a house right of course yes it's
little in 1989 ronald is thrown from a
horse six weeks later a CT scan reveals
a traumatic brain injury they drill a
hole in his skull to drain two blood
clots he takes two million in speaking
fees for a gig in Japan and people think
he's cashing in on the presidency
remember that when you would know that
was that thing that people that that was
sandal yeah and now it's just that's
part yeah it's people running for the
print people run for president knowing
they're not gonna get the nomination
just so they can get to get ready that's
right yeah that's right well I remove
potentially the man in charge of the
country right now
I think after Obama left office I think
the first gave a speech to go people and
500 people were furious as they should
be it's in 1989 Ronald oh sorry
John Poindexter is commit
five charges and sentenced to six months
its overturned on appeal Oliver North is
convicted of three charges overturned on
appeal
President Bush pardons everyone as the
investigation hones in on him just
before he leaves office in 1992 that
ends the iran-contra investigation keeps
himself out of jail it keeps it Reagan
out of jail he pardons Elliott Abrams
who now works for Donald Trump he does
and McFarlane who became an advisor on
John McCain's campaign these guys never
go away now there is no such thing as
doing something that gets your career
done they never [ __ ] I mean Henry
Kissinger is a great example that dude
now looks like a spongebob character and
he is still being like wheeled around
like blinking skin that's just like yeah
yeah yeah
not everyone that pushed for the Iraq
war all have jobs
ya know doing now when they keep ed
meese was convicted of [ __ ] and he ended
up opening up the Heritage Foundation oh
wow he's the reason that we have
Obamacare his Heritage Foundation came
up with that that's all great the
pardons were all done under the advice
and recommendation of Bush's Attorney
General William bar who currently serves
as Trump's Attorney General until
crushing it by the way great job still
crushing us doing a great job Reagan and
Bush were never charged for their crimes
of treason for an added bonus I don't
have time to go into this but the
disgraced EPA chief who refused to turn
over Superfund files to Congress and was
removed her son Neil Gorsuch placed on
the Supreme Court by Donald Trump hello
yeah it just goes to show how much Trump
is not different
oh yeah I know nothing new yeah kitty
Kelley published her all tell-all book
and brutal book about Nancy Reagan in
1991 and includes the rape allegation
that we talked about earlier People
magazine interviewed Celine Walters and
she confirmed it but not the phrase date
rape that Kitty had used quote I didn't
want him to make love to me he's a very
big man and he just had his way
date rape no god no that's Kelly's
phrase I didn't have a chance to have a
date with him
the Reagan's do not comment by the end
of Ronald Reagan's presidency 138
administrative officials had been
convicted indicted or been the subject
of investigations for official
misconduct and/or criminal violations in
terms of a number of officials involved
the record of this administration was
the worst ever in 1994 Ronald was
diagnosed with Alzheimer's on July 5th
2014 93 died at his home surrounded by
his family
earlier this year Steve ban and
resurrected human events magazine with
some other Trump personally in Obama's
second State of the Union address he
proposed a freeze in discretionary
spending and federal salaries pushed to
simplify the tax code and billions of
cuts to the defense budget
he made new calls for a bipartisan
effort to repair Social Security these
were all Reagan's positions
Time magazine quote Obama signed a
surprise 858 billion tax cut that would
have made Reagan reap with joy and then
also to me the worst thing Hillary did
on the campaign trail was say that
Ronald Reagan did a lot for AIDS
research that's really the Democratic
Party is men infected instead of
rejecting everything he is they've sort
of there's a cover where it's Obama and
Reagan arm and arm and it's like Obama
loves Reagan it's like there is that I
think and probably because of that
bulletproof appeal that you're talking
about where it's like you can't really
get to the essence of why we supported
him so blindly yet because that's what
they remember and they that's their
fantasy of you have a figure in there
where we can get all of our horrifying
[ __ ] through because yeah love them so a
great vehicle that if you criticize him
we can send you to the cornfield yeah
right you know and so they want that
again I think both parties want that
again yeah of course you know but the
fact that like they idolized Reagan but
they also like he could have gone way
farther oh yeah and that's what we're
seeing now yes and this stuff and we're
gonna see something worse down the line
that's right and when are the Democratic
Party is moved to the right where
was the right has gone off the cliff
that's right somewhere you don't even
know but but the but the off the cliff
right is gonna find a 43-year old super
fit super smart charismatic guy oh yeah
but do better pops yeah who's who's
actually good good doesn't tweet yeah
yeah if you have if you have an evil
Obama yeah you know what I mean if you I
mean Obama did [ __ ] up [ __ ] with
drones and yeah yeah the immigration
stuff but if you have that sort of
competence with Trump you know you have
what ya also this [ __ ] because every
time people go about Trump I just keep
there's this feeling I mean like I
already lived this we live this through
Reagan like aside from the tweeting and
stuff it's all the [ __ ] same except
do one thing that is different is we
have not we did not live it this
blatantly and do you know you your you
when you went to that timeline there
were this thing would happen and then
we'd have some few months of normalcy
and live our lives yeah this is every
other hour something crazy and so
there's no way to even form a thought
and you know it's true yeah it's
relentless yeah it's it's like Reagan on
like math yeah it's crazy great killer
Mike song Reagan well I'm sorry
Oh mr. peppers he's not he's not feeling
well today so thank you patent so my bad
thanks for doing this thank you
everybody for listening to 400 of us
yeah I can't wait for the 800 great
trophy all right well Happy Trails I
have we go trails yeah that ain't
pressing wait I can